then he went Donald Trump you know
Donald Trump I love Donald Trump but no
more dropped by the drop boxes are just
so bad no more drop boxes Dickinson
hologic and cephe cephahide
they sacrifice every day for the
furniture and future that was about a
guy named a rhino named Mitt Romney Mitt
Romney real Beauty had to give the
American people their voice back by
building something called truth truth
essential
he voted against Kate's law and he voted
for Obama
amnesty this is the very definition of
totalitarianism you know we've endorsed
Dr Oz we've endorsed
JP right J.D Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations than Jesse
James Billy the could some of the
world's greatest cricket players
[Music]
as the great religious teacher Swami
Vive
what said
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation the biggest lie ever
foistered upon the American people he
was awarded the bronze star and the
combat infantryman badge for his service
our army man the emperor it ran the
ramparts it took over the airports it
did everything it had to do we have to
keep our country gate prepared but it's
not I mean for some reason it's just not
great anymore if you care about law and
auto look Law and Order in normal times
roughly 40 percent of fresh vegetables
at about 40 percent China our embassies
in Kenya and Tanzania nambia's health
system is increasingly self-sufficient
shift in production to Thailand and to
Vietnam Thailand and Vietnam this is not
about virtue cycling and signing and the
great General and President Ulysses S
Grant he's done he's really come back a
long way over the last 10 years hasn't
he
we appreciate it very much Tim Apple
when they gaze upon your semites your
semonites towering Sequoias they
delivered a Swift and sweep in you know
that sweeping it was Swift and it was
sweeping like nobody's
ever seen anything happen Michigan gave
us boatength
gave us Motown gave us the Mustang units
of plasma for plasma donate plasma in
the failing New York Times by
Anonymous really an anonymous gutless
coward your Campaign Of Terror murder
Mayhem will not be tolerated any longer
it will not be allowed to go forward I
may ask Marilyn Lockheed
the leading
woman's business no teacher should ever
be allowed to teach transgender to our
children rather parental consult
no
body has to have parental consent and we
will totally oppose the Biden
administration at this this
Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements uh on Jewish
you heard them and you know them well
and let me Begin by wishing you a
beautiful like look you remember this do
you remember free health care for
illegal yeah look we inherit the legacy
of thought
and God bless
the United States thank you very much